hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve to get help
and today today amazing a question from
one of my facebook fans have fees we
wrote insane he's got a
bed-and-breakfast in Amsterdam called
rise and shine wanted some advice on how
to optimize a booking system upgrade the
property anything that will help here's
the website hotel rise and shine the NL
so I loaded it up and this is what it
looks like so at first glance this is
not a very attractive website if I'm
coming to it i'm considering booking a
stay in hall it so i look at making a
better design i would look to websites
like 99 designs com if you go to 99 99
designs.com you'll be able to get a
whole bunch of designers from around the
world to be able to create website
designs for you they'll give you a whole
bunch of options and you can figure out
which one you want to go with or not
it's an awesome system that i recommend
for all my graphic design projects so i
definitely look at that the next thing
is better pictures so if I'm looking at
this the big picture here is of the cows
now this this is not that attractive a
picture for me you're showing the
property here a little bit the flowers
are nice I would really look at getting
a professional photographer to come in
and actually take some pictures for you
even if it's on a on a contra basis so
you give them some space you know in
your in your place for a week and they
take some pictures for you because the
pictures are going to be really what
sells it right and these pictures are
not too appealing yet but I'm sure it's
a beautiful property and it could be
positioned a lot better what's going
down there's not much content on this
website so if you want to get it ranked
if you're looking for people to search
bed and breakfast amsterdam you want to
show up so you need to have more content
on here you want to update your your
title tags here you've only got home so
that should be called something else
again not enough content on this page
you want to put testimonials on here
right it's going to sell me that
somebody came to this property and had
an amazing time and it's the best place
to stay when you're coming to Amsterdam
I'm sure you've had a ton of people come
through and love what you do and put
their put your testimonies up on here
you know put it on here ideally with a
picture of them if they'd be willing to
but otherwise just their name and their
glowing words that's going to really
sell people who are coming to your site
the top navigation actually didn't even
notice it at the start it's really hard
to read this greyed out color is hard to
read before you click on it so you might
want to make that a little more visible
as well so a lot you can do on the
website it doesn't necessarily have to
cost a lot of money you know you may not
be web designers your bed and breakfast
operators but just from a few simple
tweeks you could get a lot more people
coming to your website and also
converting a lot more easily in terms of
your booking system question I don't
know what the booking system is here if
I click on apartments and rooms it shows
me some pictures again these could be a
lot nicer right this could be much
better done if you had a professional
photographer come in I guess the only
ways to contact me so that loads up an
email and I thought I saw contact at the
top contact so there is no booking
system so I don't know what dates you
have available or not and you know again
that will hold me back if I could see if
there's a date available then I don't
have to waste my time writing in to you
so I would look at creating the booking
system and I don't know what one that I
could recommend personally I'm not
involved with bed and breakfast but just
do a quick Google search you know
booking systems for bed and breakfast
you've got keep me book you've got res
Nexus you got a whole bunch of other
ones again I don't know much about these
I wouldn't recommend them necessarily
but do some research you know this you
need tools to keep your business as
automated as possible and you're also
know you're not only taking work off
your plate you're making it easier for
your customers to do business with you
which is what you want right you don't
want to create layers to make it hard
you don't want to make it hard for a
customer to do business with you so
something like like this or like this
something like this could be really
helpful in you know reducing the amount
of time you have to spend and also
making a better experience for your
customers this is great in terms of what
I talk about for testimonials see a
picture you see you know we'd love this
software boosted
sales right that's what you want to have
something ideally on your website as
well to talk about it the other thing
you can use is a website called Airbnb I
don't know if you've heard of it but
this thing keeps popping up airbnb.com
and you can list your place since you're
you have one house you can list it and
people from around the world will be
able to find it and and book with you
and they can leave testimonials and you
can show what dates you have open I
haven't used the person myself but I
know people had some great experiences
with it and so it might be worth
checking out as a as a booking system
and a way to promote your location as
well that people are coming and they're
leaving recommendations and saying that
we had a great time here it'll increase
your rankings within the Airbnb system
and you'll show up more frequently there
as well so hopefully that helps I think
it all starts with a you know better
design better layout here and then
definitely building a booking system in
again I wouldn't create it from scratch
it find the tool that is already out
there and and even looking at resources
like Airbnb that might help but take
your business to the next step good luck
I see a lot of opportunities if I do
come to Amsterdam I will I will call you
up and maybe we can meet and do some
business too for those of you watching
if you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below I'd also love to hear
what you have to think if you will want
to leave a comment under this video you
have a question for your business I
always read those comments and loves him
come in so thank you and i will see you
on the next episode
you